if you can focus all this time on trying
to be somebody that everybody else wants
you to be just do it and developing who
you want to be yeah and then see how far
you'll get because I I didn't start
doing that until like my senior year of
high school and so like you know when I
look back at it in high school there
were those kids who are like you that
used to get bullied a lot right but now
I look at look back on I'm envious of
those kids because at least they were
themselves unapologetically every
[ __ ] day in five four three two one
Hello everybody welcome to another
episode of The Genius brain podcast I am
your host David So if you haven't heard
of this podcast before you are a [ __ ]
loser and nobody loves you
I hate you so so much I hate use with
everything that I have you piece of [ __ ]
and this is where I get demonetized
because this is how I start my podcast
cheers we have two very very special
guests here we have Donovan and Jojo If
you don't know who they are [ __ ] know
about them right now I actually just
this is very interesting right this is
the first time I've ever had somebody
who started as a fan to be on this
podcast yeah ever which it doesn't
normally happen that's so good
it normally doesn't happen this way
because usually like you know fan
interactions are very one-off right yeah
like how often and how many times has
happened where I actually sit down and
get to know somebody like you don't
really see that happen
um
and so one day I get a I get a DM from
somebody right and it's really in the
off chance that I was checking my DMs
I'm getting the full story right now too
yeah like legit I I've don't check my
DMs like that right which is why I never
have brand deals
it gives me anxiety honestly I don't
want to deal with this [ __ ]
um so JoJo hits me up I have no idea who
JoJo is right yeah and I'm just like
clicking through saying thank you to a
few people here and there and I see JoJo
so I'm like oh who's this and you knew
my favorite spot to eat at which is like
cost and pie it's this place out in
South Pasadena yes and so either way I
was going to be there anyways so I'm
like you know what I might as well
so JoJo you tell the story oh my god oh
so
2020 right
yes
and Donovan I love him so much
um we were a little closer to the mic oh
hey sorry so in 2020 I reached out to
David and I was just like
how cool would it be if we met David so
just because we are both big fans but
Donovan especially like when we first
started dating he introduced you to
introduce me to your videos and I was
like that would be really really cool I
don't know if he'll do it I don't know
if he'll see my message but
I reached out it was like I think I said
hey dude would you be down to meet me
and my boyfriend
hang out with me and my boyfriend
Donovan we think you're really cool
I think I said that but like I was
definitely nervous I was like he's not
gonna see it either way but you did yeah
it was so Random too because it's like
I don't know like either way I'm gonna
eat a coffee either way so I was like
you know what if it's his birthday just
have him come through so have him say
what's up right I was like why the [ __ ]
not I'm in a happy mood and so we meet
everything is cool right the thing is
like I had no idea what you guys did I
didn't know what you did I didn't know
what she did or whatever I was just like
yeah I'm about to eat some breakfast and
I'm just gonna meet a fan and say what's
up and say hi there you go right
and so lo and behold I I I click on your
stuff I'm like oh
he does videos oh this is really really
good I do videos and then I click I was
like oh you're a dancer you both have a
huge following I had no [ __ ] idea you
know what I mean I had no idea that you
guys were also in the same entertainment
space as me I just assumed that you you
know you were fans and we were just
gonna eat some breakfast
essentially that's what it was yeah
that's really what it was and then
it was kind of odd because I think at
this space in my life there's a lot of
people who I meet who don't who I think
like in your guys's age group right the
the content that they create is is
content that I'm not really fond of
right so it's a lot of just um same old
[ __ ] you know than them coming up
scaring somebody in a park doing the
interview yeah so what what what dick
size is small is the five or the four
inches is small and they ask somebody in
the streets and I'm like oh this is
usually the content that I see three is
a great size three three is average
damage it's average yeah average it's
actually massive I didn't even know that
was like a thing that people did yeah
they think they they just walk up and
they ask people like stupid obscene
questions
it's the hottest thing right now where
they ask people dumb questions on the
street it's the end it's the interview
style content where it's just it's
easier it's repeatable and it requires
literally like zero zero prep zero
Talent or anything yeah there's like
zero talent and like there's ways to do
it where it's [ __ ] funny yeah oh yeah
it's just these people who are doing are
not funny people they're not very smart
or intelligent so it's like they're just
trying to be as famous as possible and
you know I see this content I'm like ugh
but you guys are very different I think
you guys have
you put a lot of like heart and effort
into your stuff and so for somebody who
is who has been in this space for a long
time for people like me we always look
for new people to inspire us we rarely
get inspired by people I'm not rarely
but we've already been inspired by
people who came ahead of us now we look
for a younger generation to see like oh
this is what I want to see like people
create so both of you as dancers was
pretty insane because I didn't even know
you danced until later on you know
yeah a lot a lot of people don't know I
mean it's been it's been a minute so
that we've we kind of came up out here
and I came out to LA originally to be a
dancer so what eventually end up
happening is that you know like we were
we met we danced together and then I
eventually kind of trickled off into
like film and all that because I liked
filming dancers I liked making I liked
uh being in control of how dance was
consumed on the internet and on video
and all that and so just through time
ended up being like a power couple thing
where she's the choreographer the dancer
I'm the director I'm the you know I'm
the guy that films and you know changes
all that so yeah it's been working so
far so the fact that people are like oh
you dance too and I'm like yeah it's
been it's been a minute but I can get
down still a little bit Yeah Yeah Yeah
Yeah Yeah Yeah Yeah so we we just had
dinner not that long ago and then your
guys is like personal like I had no idea
that you were living out of your [ __ ]
car which is the wildest thing ever
right and I think a lot of the times
when when we talk about people's success
stories and usually when people come on
a podcast is already by the time but by
that time they're here they're already
successful like you guys are already
very successful in what you do right but
nobody gets to hear the come up story
and I always talk about the process is
so important to who you are at the end
right and yeah and I think like that
come up story is the most inspirational
right you could see people be at the top
but you don't know what it took for
somebody to get here yeah so when you
told me that you lived out of your car
that [ __ ] blew my [ __ ] mind yeah
because I know a lot of people like when
I first came here too it was it was a
struggle like I sold everything that I
had I bought this this this this iMac I
had this this Canon uh 5D Mark II I
think at the time or some [ __ ] like that
you know it revolutionized the [ __ ]
video game
and I moved here I had this box spring
bed and this [ __ ] desk from Walmart
and I just stayed in that room and I
remember the first check that I got was
like a couple hundred bucks and I was
like oh my God I could [ __ ] buy food
yes you know so there there were those
moments so like yeah I want I want you
to just kind of like tell that story of
like how you got into like entertainment
and and the reasons why because you also
said that you were in the you were gonna
go to the [ __ ] military yeah no it's
uh so you know just just you know so
going into that so I come from a
military family my uh my father has been
in about 29 years in the Navy
um and super thankful for you know all
the time he's put in and to support our
family and with that structure it became
you know not just my dad but my
grandfather on my mom's side he was in
the Army and now my brother is in the
Navy and now my brother
it's
basically the family business so for me
it came down to like After High School
immediately it was like okay what are
you gonna do you're going to go to
college you're going to you know because
Dance For Me growing up you know
training and being a competition dancer
is how I started I trained for like six
plus years uh you know like classically
whatever trained doing everything from
hip-hop all the way down to ballet
um
figuring out what's what I'm doing after
high school was like okay are you ready
you know like let's be real are you
ready to take you ready to do something
serious you know like because you know
the margin for success in the dance
space was already so small at that time
yeah it was like okay like okay let's
take this seriously now what are you
gonna do and I didn't know I put all my
I put all my cards in into into dance
and I was like you know I didn't have
the best grades in school and that's
because I literally told told my
teachers like no I'm good I'm gonna
dance it's it's all good I don't need I
don't need the best of class I'm
convinced I convinced English [ __ ] that
yeah
I can I convinced my Algebra 2 teacher
because I I was bad I was bad at math
terrible at math
and I convinced my Algebra 2 teacher to
on the very like last day before like
report cards are due I was like hey
if if I if this if this D or F or
whatever is on this report card they're
gonna pull me out of dance so I'm gonna
need this to disappear yeah and she was
like I got you yeah so she's like all
right I'm gonna put you in algebra a b
it's not a college course or whatever
I'm gonna put you in algebra a b so you
won't get credit but I'll give you a c
in that class like just standard I was
like
bit yeah so when they did that I was
like cool and my parents didn't question
it at all I think they know this now I'm
not not sure if they do but if they now
they do yeah
how does it feel to have that pull with
your teachers
that's the one thing I I've always been
the kid that I always made friends with
the adults because I knew that if I
would get into like trouble some weird
trouble they'd be like nah he would
never do that
so
I was able to you know do dance all the
way through high school and then you
know going into uh you know adulthood
um I had I had that choice and they they
put my dad told me you know just based
on his experience it was like Hey if you
don't know what to do
we'll give you know we'll give you
structure we'll give you something to do
so you know go we'll ship you off to the
Navy like and I'm in my head I'm like
that's not what I want to do but it it's
something and this is something that I
feel like in any family uh mixed Asian
or not
it's some you know the feeling of like
doing something to make your family
proud yeah has always been like has
always been like a pillar so for me I
had to really choose like okay
I'm gonna do it I'm gonna you know I'm
gonna you know I'm gonna put my my
dancer dreams on the back burner I'm
gonna do the Navy first you know do my
four years or whatever and then who
knows what happens after that just to
make uh my family happy and you know to
give that you know that sense of like
hey I'm doing what makes uh what makes
you proud and what ended up happening
was I go to LA
I meet this one
and you know through us just interacting
and us being together you know and we're
just friends at the time uh I remember
being in full you know recruitment Garb
I go to I go to the recruitment office
and I'm just like you know I'm doing my
check-ins and then I get in the car she
was she happened to be with me on the
last day of about two weeks before I
shipped out and she was like you don't
want to do this do you and I was like
no I don't she's like then don't
you understand the weights the weight
that that carries but she was like
what we you're going to regret it like
if you don't chase your dreams now like
do you want do you really want to do
this I was like nah so instead of so
mind you the recruitment office is about
10 minutes from my house in La at the in
La is about two hours from my house so
Jesus Christ I like like my childhood
home so
I didn't go home I just went we me and
her went straight to La he came home
and uh I called my recruiter I was like
hey I'm not gonna do it uh you know like
I'm gonna I'm gonna chase my dreams and
he was like are you sure and I was like
and when he asked me that question I was
like
yeah no bit we're doing it yeah but the
back of my thought was the back of my
head was
he's gonna call my dad after this
he's gonna call my dad am I sure so sure
enough I laid I laid down I let it I let
him know I'm like okay cool we're good
10 minutes after that call that's
[ __ ] crazy that is too fast [ __ ]
snitch snitch ass recruiter this
[ __ ] said are you sure he goes
all right dude guess what
just back the [ __ ] out of this thing get
him no but yeah then my dad called me
you know we had it we you know I it's
really strained our relationship at that
point because it was something where my
dad and you know even now like me and my
dad are great like yeah me and my dad
are great me and my mom are great our
relationship is super um super good and
they they're in complete support of
everything that we do
um now as a married couple as well along
in including the journey but back then
it was really strained because it was
all my dad knew he knew that it provided
for his family for our family and it was
like how else are you going to do that
so for him it was like you know you
choosing this path like
like like not like don't you know don't
disrespect what I did by saying no to
this path and it took me a long time to
understand
why it upset him so much and for a year
you know like for for a hot minute for
years it was like there was always like
this subtle like distance because
because I was I was straight up zoned
for a bit you know like I know so you
know like you know Dad nah cut him off
mom
all right sweetie you know figure it out
for a bit I gotta you know I gotta you
know we gotta take we gotta figure this
out
um so that's when I was like okay so I
lived in my car uh my 2004 Mitsubishi
Lancer tell you had a Mitsubishi Lancer
that is the brokest car yeah
[ __ ] that is the poor person's [ __ ]
ID card right there yeah
it was stock too I didn't have the money
to like make it look
[ __ ] it uh what do you call that [ __ ] oh
that's so [ __ ] funny dude but um yeah
that's you know so I went to LA I lived
out of that um and it was just I spent
an entire year
um of just primarily just sleeping in my
car crashing at her place crushing out
my boy uh Tyrone's Place shout out to
Tyrone
um and I was able to kind of like I
struggled through it but I just kept on
telling myself I'm doing I'm out here
doing what I love so the hardest parts
were always waking up and going to sleep
everything in between was like all right
I'm dancing I'm good to go waking up you
got like you got like knots in your back
you're you're your knees are hurting
because you haven't been able to fully
stretch out because Mitsubishi Lancers
are small
that tried breaking into your car when
you were asleep
I don't know why it makes me laugh it's
the way he tells the story it's really
not funny I'm kind of Twisted for
laughing no that's funny to explain this
[ __ ] to me right now
we forgot to mention this at dinner so
in the car so so I'm in the car right so
sleeping in your car is dangerous yeah I
didn't understand that concept because
in my head I was like yeah you're in
your car people don't do that they don't
be checking cars and all that so me I'm
sleeping in my car I didn't at the time
I thought
I thought that putting a sheet over the
windows would be enough to be like hey
this is private there's someone in here
I'm sleeping in here yeah I'm sleeping
in here yeah so I put like I'm literally
making adult pillow forts in my car
because I that's I was just like here's
what I got to do five dollar sheet from
wherever and Bam so I'm in my car
sleeping
and this is kind of what kind of really
motivated me to like get out of the
situation because I mind you at this
point I had already been in there for
like five months so I was I was I got I
found a system I had a routine like I
knew to go to the local dance studio or
the gym to like you know to keep my
hygiene up I knew to uh you know where
to get my food I knew like you know my
timing and all that so
at this moment though it was like it was
like 2 A.M or something and I'm watching
David's so videos this is so true oh my
God this is so true I'm watching videos
and this is what this is another big
part to kind of circle back on it too
like I've been watching you for a long
time so for me motivation wise like
um as a young as a young mixed Asian I
always looked up to like your content
and other people's content because it
was it was something that made me laugh
it was something that inspired me and it
kept me going that was the biggest thing
that kept me going like I always looked
forward to those videos like your old
Vlog videos when you would you know you
would watch uh watch a video that
someone sent you on like something and
then you would react to it or all that
kind of stuff so I I love that content
and that content got me through a lot of
my my lonely car nights so
and what happened was is I'm watching a
video
and I hear someone mind you I'm in the
back seat of my car someone is trying to
get in the car I'm like this I'm like
huh like I'm like uh this is happening
okay so here's the funny part
I have I had a replica Colt 45 uh pistol
a replica it was
disassembled whatever it was but it was
the same casing it was still like it
looked like a real just on fire just
doesn't fire I had that because my
brother was gifted that for one of his
birthdays because you know that's like
he was into uh like guns and all that at
a younger age to um because he knew that
he was going to eventually go into the
Navy
but what he didn't know is that you know
going to La I thought to myself I'm like
I might need to keep this on me for
whatever reason out of your [ __ ] car
yeah so
I have it in my middle console so I'm in
the back seat laid out like this like
this and I'm like I behind the sheet I
see the Shadow trying to get in I go
into my middle console I pull out the
gun and I go like this like put my hand
under the sheet and I go
like that and he's like I hear oh [ __ ]
and then eat like runs away and I went
I need to get out of here
I was like this this ain't right it was
the same with the [ __ ] you better run
[ __ ] he's like does he feel like he's
crying is he crying but I'm scared you
sobbing in the car what the [ __ ] what no
no let me run this back yeah it's a tap
tap tap that kills me God that's so
that's so you know that's actually kind
of frightening on the other side like
this [ __ ] has a gut you know and
they're out well mind you all he sees is
a busted down Mitsubishi Lancer with
taped Windows yeah taped Windows it was
it was at that point and just that'd be
so funny he's still so bad for you he
just wanted to give you like some money
yeah he just started sliding a dollar
through the window correct ah [ __ ] give
me that back because I feel bad for you
they saw that so wait so you you
explain how you met him okay so Donovan
and I we met at a clear Talent meet and
greet so we are ready to the mic hey
sorry you can angle it down for yourself
too
there you go is this better here you go
thank you I've never been on a podcast
before Oh my gosh yeah okay actually
you're the first this is the first
podcast you're doing great this is great
I'm [ __ ] fascinated I love the
stories thanks so Donovan and I we met
at this dance event it's called the
clear Talent meet and greet that happens
every year clear Talent is our talent
agency that we're both rep behind so
they both represent us as dancers
somehow even though I haven't booked a
dance job in like doesn't matter it
doesn't matter they're like they're like
keep signing that contract I'm like I
got you yeah just in case yeah but I I
had been signed already for a couple of
years and I would attend those meet and
greets every year and so this particular
year I saw
this guy in the back of the room and he
had on I think you had a black hat with
black gloves and his hat was on like
really really low he literally looked
like Channing Tatum
literally Channing Tatum in the back of
the room I was like who the hell is it's
been a long time and and he was just so
talented we were learning choreography
in this dance class and then we would
take that choreography and we would
perform it at the El Portal in North
Hollywood and then all of these
Executives and creative directors and
other choreographers that were looking
for dancers to hire they would come and
they would watch us and so there were a
bunch of ctg clients there and he was a
new client so I'd never seen him before
so I'm watching him staring at him from
all the way across the room I'm like who
the hell is this well staring at him for
a little too long and he had a really
mysterious Vibe so mysterious he was
just hungry and poor
you would never know you would literally
never know the way that he carried
himself it was just sexy and mysterious
so I was like
tired and hungry he's like oh he's so
quiet it's because I haven't eaten his
days
like dead ass I would have never known
the way that he carried himself and so I
went up to him once we got to the El
Portal right before the show started I
was like hey I like grabbed the song I
was like hey he was like sup I was like
no no my name's JoJo nice to meet you
and he was like Hey so then we we
proceeded to practice the routine
together and then um approached him oh
yeah I approached him yes because I was
so like
I'm in L.A yeah yeah I'm focused yeah
and then she you know she kind of in
like in a literal and figurative sense
at the same time she be so she was the
first person I ever talked to out here
because so for me I spent I spent a lot
of time alone just you know going
through my Paces so no one really knew
who I was like because and that's
because I had such a chip on my shoulder
to succeed that I was in that like I'm
in La I'm not gonna talk to nobody I'm
gonna make my money grind it out yeah
yeah while I'm living in my car eating
peanut butter
pulls my arm and is like hey and in that
moment I'm like a friend yeah this
shining Beacon of light right here yeah
so yeah then she let me know like hey
like I teach um and mind you so I'm
gonna Gasser up real quick she teaches
sold out classes weekly and has worked
with
100 like 100 plus people per class and
she's worked with like really big music
artists in the industry like you know
over the years at this point she only
had around five people in her class so
like this is it was towards like the
humble beginnings of her choreographer
and the dancer career of that sets
because actually no just your
choreographer career because you've been
dancing already for a minute but I was
like yeah I'll come take she didn't know
that I was living in my car and also
driving two hours like whenever I had to
be in L.A yeah so she was like come
every day come whenever you can I was
like all right cool just going and then
he literally showed up at my class like
if was it the next day like a couple
days okay the next day and I was a sub I
didn't even have my own teaching slot
yet so yeah this was my like beginning
of my career I didn't know where it was
going to take me I was just doing it for
fun and I wanted it to be around good
energy and Donovan had great energy so I
was like I don't know if you'll remember
that I told him my class was at this
time at this place but it was nice
meeting him you know so
yeah he showed up to my class the next
day and I was teaching to 7-Eleven by
Beyonce and it was like the girliest
routine ever like it was a heels routine
and I had never had a male dancer in my
class before and it was a big deal for
me because I mean I love teaching but
when you have a really really talented
male come to your class especially back
then it was a really really big deal and
so he absolutely killed it in my class
and he made it super super masculine
like he without me even having to say
anything he made it his own and I fell
in love not like romantically in that
way but I fell in love with him as like
the talented person that he was I was
like oh my God like I want to be in his
life I I want to actually be close to
him I want him invested in my business I
was like I need to be in this guy's life
like he's so talented he's funny he's
nice he's sexy like what the hell is
this like I need to know more about them
so I posted them on my Instagram that
saying I was like oh my God look at this
delicious bundle of like sexiness that
came to my class today
and uh we stayed close and I got 500
followers that day that was such a funny
joke I was like I was like
what's happening no mind you me and my
parents aren't really tweaking at this
point but I do text my mom so I texted
my mom like I'm making it yeah yeah yeah
like you know just like the small it was
like the small little like feedback of
yay I got tagged on Instagram and
something like that but I didn't even
have a lot of followers back then this
was when you could post 15 second clips
over time you had over 10K having the K
was everything back then just it was it
really was yeah so yeah I know and yeah
I kept attending her classes and you
know eventually we ended up working
together even more and
and then love blossomed and it's kind of
crazy too like
I feel like women are so good at looking
at things Beyond physical
characteristics right more than more so
than men because you you liked Donovan
because you saw something in him right
like you saw something about him that
made you really attracted to and it's
interesting because when you so when you
came here and you were living out of
your car right
like that whole that whole process for
you like what was like the the like the
mental [ __ ] that you were going through
because for me when I first started and
I didn't have any money that that would
like [ __ ] with me a lot yeah I mean like
mentally it [ __ ] with me a lot because
when you come into this city everybody
likes to flaunt what they have they
always say like it like Ellie is about
what you what it's like what you drive
and what you wear and Ella and New York
is about where you live so here
everybody has this position to kind of
show how important they are by how much
money they have and like that type of
notoriety and but because I grew up so
[ __ ] broke I never gave a [ __ ] about
any of this like I was also a youth
Minister I was a pastor So Physical
things don't matter to me you know what
I mean it's always about life
experiences meeting great people yeah so
obviously I understand like when you
came here you had to have this
perception of like okay I'm in La now
now I have to do la [ __ ] yeah to make
sure that people don't [ __ ] with me or
they know who I am so likely I had I had
the biggest wall up because I was I was
afraid of that like you know like in
terms of
um you know because because you always
hear the the stories especially when you
you know when you're the outside looking
in you always hear the stories of like
Ellie's Cutthroat and it's very clicky
and it's like you know there's a lot of
you know like certain things that go
with it all of it true by the way but
but
the way that I was raised was instead of
like showing off what you have because I
didn't have that much obviously when I
was out there and I I you know I like I
can't say that I grew up like
poor but we grew up with the because you
know like my parents grew up they you
know they grew up with like at a point
they were like bankrupt or something
like that yeah but I didn't know because
if they would know this they wouldn't
tell us yeah you know like as a so if I
had ramen noodles every night I was like
lit ramen noodles I love ramen or my mom
had these things called fend for
yourself nights and that basically meant
there's a there's a full pot of rice
go make something whatever the hell's in
the cabinet yeah yeah so we always had
like either Ramen uh Vienna sausages
shout out to Vienna sausages
spam all of it so that's that's my [ __ ]
oh yeah so yeah um but mentality wise I
was taught it's not about like what you
have it's about the way you make people
feel yeah um and I that's always stuck
with me throughout it so like for me
like when it came to the mixed groups
that I've been in in terms of like
whether they were well off or whether we
were all roughing it together it was it
was always about I always cared about
the way I made people feel and the
impression that I made on them almost to
like almost to like almost too much
sometimes where I'd be like you know and
a couple of people please yeah and
people would take advantage of that
eventually 100 so yeah I get that yeah
so
I mean for you to like
I guess like when you saw because when
you were together you were living in the
car but she had a place but you didn't
want to stay with her yeah because so
out and this was mostly out of respect
remember like so she her parents don't
know who I am they are very protective
of her especially back then like my
parents are so protective over me that
they it they didn't want like my
boyfriend's in the house because my dad
Cuban man I know everyone's parents are
different but my dad did not want boys
in the apartment at all even if I lived
there on my own and they weren't there
they just felt very weird about it so
and in hindsight like I get it
absolutely right yeah like yeah get it
don't let him in so with that being said
the her being living at a place in me
you know and mind you we are still
friends at this point
I wanted to be super respectful so she
would even be like hey come stay inside
I'd be like nah I'm gonna I'm gonna stay
like I'll stay in the car I'll crash the
Tyrone's place I'll be anywhere but here
and she was like you know she respected
it and it even got to the point
sometimes where she'd be like
I'll come I'll come I'll come sleep in
the car with you I'll make some
fettuccine
look at him yeah we can hang out and I'm
like yeah I'm like you didn't get to
that point it didn't get to that point
we started dating before that point
happened because then I was worth it but
but um yeah so I mean in terms of our
relationship like she was the first
person to really
show me that La wasn't such a such a
hard place
um that you can find your your people
you can find your village and your your
circle and I held that deer so I kept up
with those morals I protected her
because I didn't anyone that I saw that
was like kind of going off signs of was
always and people know me for this I'm
I'm silly I'm funny I like to crack
jokes and I like to have a good time but
if you don't know me I'm very
standoffish sometimes and I can and it
almost comes up that's exactly how I am
like like people won't people be like oh
Donovan hates me like nah he doesn't
hate you he just doesn't he doesn't
exactly what it is so
so and I learned that from you by the
way probably I mean that's how I am 100
and like the reason why is too you know
I've I've thought about this a lot is
like
I I've definitely met a lot of people in
this world who are very likable right
and likable doesn't mean you're a good
person right and yeah people like to use
this this this skill this tool that they
have to get close to people and you you
think that you know them because they're
very good at lying about who they are so
it's it's a very tough world like that
right yes and so I've I've kept here's
this I mean I'll go back to this but one
of the things that I really enjoyed and
I know this is something really odd but
when I attended their wedding which by
the way I [ __ ] hate weddings
I don't know what it is about YouTube
that I really [ __ ] like uh you know
and the more more I hear about your
story it makes sense and I I must I'm
somebody who kind of goes with their gut
feeling right yeah
and thanks for coming to our wedding now
thank you so much the [ __ ] wedding
was [ __ ] dope
it was [ __ ] amazing and so when I
I saw that when you were up there and I
saw your your groom Spin and your guys
surprised me it's like it's like people
that you grew up with now I don't see
that a lot in the city people come into
the City and they forget everybody that
they know they go I'm I'm this new
invented human being yeah people have
that they that they that help them be
who they are today they forget about
them like that and that is a true tell
sign of how they are as an individual
I saw your friends from how you grew up
and they were all there with you yeah I
was like I I knew I knew I liked this
guy you know and I've had the same
friends since ever right and when I came
to this city whenever I go back it's all
the same I'm the same [ __ ] loser in
the group they don't give a [ __ ] about
me
Kyle paragus and Christian mag Day
friends of 20 and 18 years
I'm on the genie see this brain podcast
we all grew up watching David so you
know having David so so yeah it was just
a it's a really genuine moment and
having having them up there they're the
friends that
no matter where I went I'm told that
we've sat down many times like we've had
dinner
um whenever they drive out to LA like oh
like I got there I got their dinner like
I'll like I'll pay for whatever they
need to pay for because it's you know
it's a lot to drive out that far yeah
and I've let them know like on a date on
on a weekly basis if I have to that hey
like Wherever I Go
y'all are coming with me yeah yeah and
they know that at this point and you
know I'm like my best man you know it
was crazy even when I asked him because
I've had made so many other types of
friends since then and it's like okay
yeah you see those guys on a daily basis
and we only see each other like once a
month sometimes maybe even longer and
you know when I asked him it was almost
like wow
he didn't forget about me yeah yeah and
I would never forget about them so
that's you know those are the people
that were up there and then you know
along with every era of my friends my
family uh my OG boys from home uh my my
friend Tyrone that I you know he was up
there too and then uh and then right
Michael my most recent like close close
friend yeah everyone that was up there
and including on her side they're all
from different parts of our upbringing
and we're very selective and we're very
like everyone that was there was meant
to be there was it hard for you when you
were kind of like starting up and you
know you mentioned earlier
that you know the hardest parts when you
weren't busy was like waking up in the
morning and then going to sleep at night
and like how did you deal with that
because those were the hard parts for me
too because I'm not distracted by all
the stuff that I'm trying to do and I
just left alone and that was like the
that was the hard part right because
you're you're kind of just like
you can this is what happened in
pandemic too everything that we were
allowed to push aside we had a face
right here a lot of people got divorced
a lot of people split up people left
their jobs because now that you can't be
distracted with bars hanging out going
out doing all this other [ __ ] you were
left alone with your thoughts and now
you have to face it so how did you deal
with it because I know that shit's
[ __ ] rough
I mean the the best
the way that I got through it from a
mental aspect even was
I kind of just I I mean I took it day by
day I was like okay Sunday through
Saturday how am I gonna make this work
okay hello my boy hey man can I crash
once this week that's one day out of my
way hey
can I you know can I come drive my car
to in front of your place and be there
or head up another friend if I could get
a couple of those days out of the week
in terms of like making sure that I'm
not in my car every day
then it was a better week than me being
in my car the entire week which happened
quite frequently so for me
what got me up was
the feel like the worst part is the
waking up and being like
because you know you're not running your
car all night so you're you're in there
the second it's like an airtight seal so
you're just in there like
[Music]
genius farts this podcast is brought to
you by athletic greens oh do I love my
ag1 because it is easy to scoop and put
in my water and one and done I'm
absorbing 75 high quality vitamins
minerals Whole Foods sourced ingredients
probiotics and adaptogens to help start
my day right well I'll tell you this
special blend gets me going and I'm
telling you right now helps me in every
every bit of a way when it comes to my
health why do I personally consume it
well I'll tell you why it's easy I don't
like taking pills I just drink it with
my water and I need to drink more water
every day anyway so I might as well do
it with my athletic green supports
better sleep quality and recovery and
mental Clarity which I need for this
podcast to make it easy athletic greens
is going to give you a free one-year
supply of immune supporting vitamin D
and five free travel packs with your
purchase all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com geniusbrain again
that is athleticgreens.com to take
ownership of your health health and pick
up the ultimate daily nutritional
insurance
and then like you open up the door like
you feel like you're you're coming out
from like a 60-year sleep nah but
honestly it was the it was the not
wanting to be in that situation that
kept me going in that sense so from a
mental standpoint whether it was like
because there would be nights where like
I would cry myself to sleep sometimes
because I chose I you know at the end of
the day this was all my choice I had the
choice to go home I had the choice to
like my parents never
they you know they there was a point
where it was like yeah disowned but
doors were never closed like yeah no
he's gonna come to us he's like he's
like yeah he's going to come back like
he's going to come back and I chose to
not go back so for me it was almost the
there was a little bit of I'm gonna
prove you wrong energy along with
I I gotta make it like I have to so
I just made it I made it I just made it
a a better situation every time I would
treat myself to a different brand of
peanut butter
we're not going Kroger today we're going
Jiffy baby let's go yeah let's go we're
gonna chunky yeah we're gonna treat
ourselves
um those struggle
let me let me tell you but um oh and at
the time oh actually one thing that I
can say that and like I said the mental
the mental ways was finding the littlest
things to make you happy and for me a
lot of the time was like you know didn't
have a lot of money for food I got money
for food now but I didn't have a lot of
money for food I would make you know
everything like no like I would get my
only my favorite things so like example
my if it was I was raised on struggle
food so I was like this is easy I can do
this yeah let's let's go or example if I
wanted to treat myself Ralph's used to
leave their baked goods on like a place
they don't do this now ever since covid
but they used to have their baked their
leftover baked goods that were sitting
there all day for free like for anyone
to take so I would literally like I
would I would stroll up in there I
didn't have any money to pay for Ralph's
food but I was like
yeah
I'm eating Donuts tonight baby yeah yeah
yeah it'll be on the it'll be at the end
of the week so it'll be like you know
and then that would be like my Friday
night and if I was like hanging with my
buddies we wouldn't uh mind you none of
my friends also had money to like be
like going out get drinks and all that
so instead I was also like 19 so like
you know it was hard to do anything
because I wasn't I wasn't one of those
guys that was like you could get a fake
ID no I can't I don't know how to do
that yeah yeah
I'll do any of that so
um we would just go out and this is
actually how I kind of got into filming
is I would have an iPhone I still had an
iPhone we would film ourselves dancing
at like 3 A.M like all the way through
the night find like cool locations
throughout La trespass into some
construction sites
yeah and film film some stuff and just
you know have a good time and those are
still some of my favorite memories to
this day like even though I'm at the
point now where
I don't have to do that I'm like should
I just run it back for the one like I'll
help my friend like yo should we should
we go do that and then by the time and
by the time please and by the time it
hits 12 o'clock though I'm like I'm
tired like I can't do the because we
would literally be up from all hours of
night till 8 A.M just not doing it
because imagine I don't want to go back
to my car yeah yeah so if I have to be
like a crazy night owl and then you know
I'll come up to my boy's crib and he's
like hey bro we were up all night like
just crash just crash on the it wasn't a
couch it was a floor yeah it was a floor
mat so it was like come crashing the
floor mat I was like yeah fine I was
like yes not in the car we're good yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so it was it
was the connections I've made with those
people
along with time management along with
keeping myself looking like
keeping something for me to look forward
to those are the things that mentally
kept me sane and
I always had her her classes weekly to
always look forward to too so yeah I was
I was able to keep that up and then
eventually I had the opportunity to get
myself out of it in a very
um in a small way but it ended up being
like a really big opportunity for me to
like just change my life entirely and
that was picking up the camera and
starting videography
um and once I did that I was like I
could start I you know I talked to my
buddy I was like hey I don't got a lot
of money but I can pay like a certain
amount of rent just to you know not be
on the street and he was like bet let's
do it wow so and I never I never went
back to the car since that's [ __ ]
crazy man like I like I said too like
that struggle [ __ ] is so real and when
we look back some of sometimes like the
parts that were the hardest were some of
the most fun moments of Our Lives oh
yeah because we have nothing to lose
I literally have nothing to lose so if I
fail okay I'm at Rock Bottom
it doesn't get much lower than this I
know over here [ __ ] cry eating peanut
butter watching this fat asian guy
I just like this is a low point of my
[ __ ] life right now you know you
can't take anything from me at this
point you looks great by the way
oh my God it looks great yes I've seen
the the shrinking throughout the years
and it's very inspiring I'm gonna be
honest when I was in the car I was very
skinny so now I'm like you know what I'm
getting inspired by this because your
life is too good dude I need some
struggle you're gonna I want you to go
buy back that [ __ ] Mitsubishi Lancer
yes go back in that [ __ ] car suddenly
you're so thin it's just so hilarious
it's interesting man like I I really do
appreciate like how you how both of you
have such a very strong drive towards
building something that a lot of people
don't do right so
I think that we're so we're in this age
where everybody wants to try to do
everything but you guys seem to be very
focused on what you do specifically you
as a Dancer too I had no idea how
[ __ ] huge you were I mean I didn't
know like no I don't know these things
you know and I'm like I was like oh wow
she's a great dancer what is this a
million views who the [ __ ] is this like
that was shocking to me right because it
was just oh I'm meeting these people
that have breakfast and then I'm like
who the [ __ ] is this and let me tell you
something sometimes I'm watching you I'm
like oh you're I always say this we were
having dinner I'm like look at those
knees
[Laughter]
okay so how did you get into dance
so well really young age I was like five
and I had a lot of energy as a kid and
it was just always like as soon as my
mom signed me up for my first Jazz class
that was it
um I fell in love with it immediately
and then my senior year I was like I
can't picture myself doing anything else
and I didn't know anything about LA or
the entertainment industry I was just
really loving what I was doing every
single day I had a dance room in my
house in Massachusetts that's where I'm
from I'm from the east coast and so
I was like I don't know what my future
will hold but I know I don't want to go
to college like I had a whole
scholarship to go to amda and I scouted
it and it was like
it seemed cool but it wasn't what I
wanted to do like I knew I wanted to do
music videos and Commercial dance I
didn't want to do modern and ballet and
that like really structured militant
style so my mom was like we're gonna
give you one year in La we're gonna move
out there with you for a year and if you
don't work or if you don't get signed
then that's it you're gonna come back to
Massachusetts so
it was like a contract that I made with
them too like I was serious I was like
okay let's let's make it official like
let me sign my life away I will make
this happen that's pretty interesting
how you were 18 at the time uh no I was
17. Jesus Christ but you were that
focused huh I was so focused because I
also like when I was in school I not to
make it sound like this but I didn't
have a lot of friends in high school and
I was bullied for being a dancer because
I'm from like bum [ __ ] Massachusetts
okay I went to a Catholic school you're
not marrying your cousin what the [ __ ]
right it's funny because every time she
describes it it's always bum [ __ ]
messages from bum [ __ ] Massachusetts
it's not just Massachusetts it's bum
[ __ ] Massachusetts
I went to Catholic school and I just
didn't fit in with anyone over there I
was like this weird girl that missed
every Monday and Friday of school and
they would see all these pictures of me
at dance conventions like all over the
countries throughout the week all over
the country throughout the week weekend
and then I would come back and then my
hair would be a different color because
I was finding myself as well creatively
and I would get inspired everywhere I
went and so I would get picked on and
then I there were like days where
people would just make snarky comments
at me there was one day where this girl
printed out my very first head shots
that I put on Facebook and they put my
pictures all over the lockers and they
ripped my face off dude why it's like
crazy so [ __ ] mean dude but I kind of
liked it oh I kind of liked it because I
was like wow they're so obsessed with it
I was like wow they always say this to
like guys would physically bully
somebody girls like to [ __ ] mentally
yeah with you dude it's crazy it's ten
times worse just beat me up like just
[ __ ] songs in your face like don't do
this [ __ ] you know my misery yeah you
know they would make fun of me but in my
head I was like you know what they're
all basic [ __ ] like in the back of my
head like I wouldn't cry I would just
look at them sideways like
I know I'm the one that's getting picked
on and bullied in school but they have
no idea how legendary I'm gonna be in
life like I I knew it and it was set in
my head already like it clicked in my
head one day that I wasn't gonna stop
until I made my parents proud until I
proved them wrong because they also
wanted me to work at
um their family business they didn't
want me to go to LA because they wanted
me all to themselves like we have a very
close Bond but they also weren't sure if
being a professional dancer was going to
be secure for me so which I understand
how they feel you have to work really
hard in order to make consistent money
as a professional dancer but I wanted it
so bad like I was willing to fail I was
willing to do whatever it took in order
for me to do what I love every single
day so when they gave me that one year I
hustled I hustled really really hard I
would take seven classes a day I would
go to the gym oh yeah no and my mom
would take me my mom and dad they would
take me to these class and then we would
eat in the car during the breaks and
even before that I would wake up and
I'll go to the gym at night I would take
a hot yoga class and then I would go to
sleep I would eat a meal and then I
would wake up and do it all over again
yeah I'm back in the best shape of my
life and I was like how the [ __ ] have
you ever seen back ABS I gotta send you
the photo but I had like a four pack
it's crazy behind my back
same I know that's I was so focused you
know what's interesting I think like one
of the things that both of you have in
common is like this very strong identity
of self right when we were talking uh
yesterday too like hearing your story
and your stories like you guys kind of
never
straight away from
like loving your individuality right
which is very [ __ ] hard to do when
you're young like that took me a long
long long time and you guys already had
something about you that I didn't have
at your age like when you were telling
me your stories about you just being
that weird anime kid where you were cut
this well this [ __ ] by the way I
wore the jersey I wore the jersey he
said he would show up in school just
dress up as a ninja this is so true yeah
I had the Tabby Boots the the whole ghee
the whole thing like it wasn't like it
wasn't no Walmart [ __ ] yeah like I was
like imma get the authentic thing like
it took me like two weeks it shipped out
got it I would get picked on a lot but
see this is what I'm saying like I feel
like I [ __ ] up in high school all the
way until my last year because I always
tried to do something that I wasn't I
was like six different people and that
was so exhausting because you're so
scared of personal judgment and this is
where I always say too like if you can
focus all this time on trying to be
somebody that everybody else wants you
to be just do it and developing who you
want to be yeah and then see how far
you'll get because I did and start doing
that until like my senior year of high
school and so like you know when I
looked back on in high school there were
those kids who were like you that used
to get bullied a lot right but now I
look at look back on I'm envious of
those kids because at least they were
themselves unapologetically every
[ __ ] day and you had to sit there and
take all the scrutiny right and just be
on just understand like this is who I am
yeah like I'm not going to change who I
am because what other people want and it
took me all the way till I was 18 to
figure that [ __ ] out because I wanted to
be I still wanted to watch anime with my
anime friends but then after you know
school at night time I was like wanting
to kick it with these thugs because I
wanted to be a tough guy and then you
were just I was just a phony in this
group I was a phony in this group I'm a
phony in that group I'm a phony because
I just wasn't happy being who I was and
so but you guys figured that out so
[ __ ] early on and like seeing that
too I could see why you guys are such so
successful at an earlier age and I
always talk about this too because
people don't understand how hard it is
to lie about yourself every day it's
hard you got to keep that face up every
[ __ ] day every day and you have to
remember these lies all the [ __ ] time
so when you're around this person oh I
don't want them to think I'm this this
and that so I have to be this person and
then you turn it off and you go
somewhere else you have to be somebody
else is such an exhausting way to live
so yeah and I think like for for young
people too they're they're scared of
being themselves because of that
judgment but I'm telling you right now
like you will find that Circle that
accepts who you are and those are the
people that you focus on the most when
you when you focus so much on being this
fake human being and I don't mean faking
like the typical sense of like being a
bad person I mean like fake in the sense
that you're not who you are right
all that [ __ ] catches and you'll find
yourself one day who you'll wake up and
you go oh I actually don't have friends
because yeah they'll either use you and
they'll go to something else or maybe
you're that person who'll use them and
you'll go to something else and they'll
[ __ ] cut you out and you go oh these
people were never my friends no you were
never their friend yeah you know
entirely yeah yeah and that's why when I
saw that you guys have such a strong
group of friends around you having a
good time like that was very very
important for me like watching you at
the wedding and like like I said I saw
you with for instance you were in high
school and you've amounted all the
success but you still carry the people
that are that built who you are till
this day shows like really good
character in you right and I don't see
that a lot sometimes like I in your
guys's age group and how fast life moves
it's very important so when I hear your
story about look I was bullied in high
school people didn't know who the [ __ ] I
was and I just had to be like I have
greatness in me I have to believe in
this [ __ ] and when I leave here I'm
gonna show people right and I guarantee
you too people come out the woodwork
they do dude I remember people in high
school like yo I'm proud of you I'm like
who are you yeah yeah
I don't even know your first and last
name oh yeah who are you I have a crazy
story about that it's short but like the
first job that I booked in La was the
VMAs and it was for the Britney Spears
Vanguard is that you say Vanguard award
uh yeah yeah so I was 17 and it was my
first audition out there and I had just
gotten signed so when you get signed you
get sent to the really really big
auditions for like the TV shows and all
that so my mom's like okay Joanna this
like your first big audition I was like
all right I'm just gonna go there and
like treat it as a dance class for you
know a lesson I book it and I remember
when I went on TV
or before I went on TV that very day of
the VMAs I put on Facebook you'll see a
familiar face on the VMAs and nobody
commented on it because they're like I'm
sure they didn't believe that I was
going to be on the amazed when I was on
the VMAs I had such a clear like shot I
was one of the main three girls that
popped up for Oops I did it again and
basically in the performance Brittany
wasn't in it it was a tribute to her
where we did we did all of her she was
literally in the audience watching us
and we performed all of her iconic
choreographies and I'm a young girl and
she's my Holy Grail like she's the
reason why I started dancing and I
wanted to be an artist and all that so
that was very full circle for me so I
had a clear shot on TV like you could
tell that it was me it was like night
and day like that's JoJo oh my god there
she is and so
there were so many people commenting and
tagging me in photos saying oh my God
look at my friend Jojo and it's like
this girl that used to bully me in
school Jesus Christ and she's like oh my
god when are you gonna come back to
Massachusetts and hang out with us I was
like like weren't you like bullying me
in school like it's just so crazy the
people that you know bullied you for
what you were doing on the weekends all
the hard work that you were putting in
or when you I would come back and I
would have like a different color in my
hair to be different those people that
made fun of me they were pretending to
be my friend because they always wanted
to be that's why they always wanted to
be that person who had your type of
confidence that was very focused because
they didn't have anything going on in
their lives and you know when I used to
hear this stuff too I used to be like oh
is that really what's going on in their
head but that's really what it is happy
people don't do that to other people
right when you're happy and you're
focused on your own goals you don't go
out of your way to make somebody feel
bad when they're not doing anything to
you at all literally right and like so
by the way if I if you ever see me bully
somebody on here it's because
I hate them they're pieces of [ __ ] all
right you just don't know why I I won't
give out the reasons it's just they're a
piece of [ __ ] but
that's what happens like these people
who were so and you'll see these people
in high school because you're from bum
[ __ ] nowhere bum [ __ ] you know so you
know these bum [ __ ] people that you knew
they're probably still doing the same
[ __ ] [ __ ] that they're always doing
and they're sitting there just hating on
everybody else because I guarantee you
that same person who says like oh this
is my friend they're still talking [ __ ]
about you though oh hell yeah right yeah
they're still talking [ __ ] about you God
I love it you know and you're gonna
continue to amount to whatever type of
success that you have and you're going
to continue to do it and every day is
going to eat them up inside right and
that turns me on
it should though like it really does
right because
it's kind of sad when I see people
and I don't mean to say this to make me
feel better but I find it very sad when
somebody wakes up every day and they
have to write or you live in their head
[ __ ] rent free and you're just doing
what you're doing right yeah and it's
the craziest thing and they want you to
think about them so [ __ ] hard so they
want reactions yeah they'll keep writing
these comments they'll do something and
then finally when you react they think
oh I got you but it's like for us on the
end where it's like no I just wrote one
comment back to you and I'm about my day
and I'm still doing what I'm doing
Moving on but for them it's it's the
saddest thing that they finally got that
response and now they're alive they're
like oh I got them I need more yes more
and they wake up the next day and they
try to write another comment to affect
you yep and so it's like it's crazy it's
kind of insane and that's what I'm
saying like unhappy people behave this
way right when you're happy you don't
you don't care and you two are very
happy people I'm pretty sure you're not
sitting around going time to get on
Reddit and I talk some [ __ ] you know and
that's like the highlight of your day I
have a ghost account for that
I really do want to create a burner
account so bad I I want to do it but it
just too much time you know like I gotta
do other things you know I mean if I'm
sitting here creating a burner account
like [ __ ] you you ugly [ __ ] you
know
usually when I respond back people know
this and I was like I'm taking a [ __ ]
so I'm like all right let me just just
write something back you you are a loser
and I [ __ ] your mom son all right
honestly I love responding to hate
comments sometimes because it really
makes me giggle yeah sometimes it's fun
sometimes it's fun that's engagement too
yeah it's great engagement all of a
sudden you have more comments because
yeah you're going back and forth do I
recently try to try to beat up somebody
because this dude was like threatening
me and I'm like oh oh well so you know I
posted these like Fitness videos because
yep a lot of people have been losing
weight with me yes and I you know when I
first started doing this stuff I didn't
realize that again there me being me
being like a bigger person and like you
know being big wasn't an issue with me
it was just like when I hit to like 27
28 I started like feeling it and that
was the part that was [ __ ] me up it's
like oh like heartburn and like my
stomach was hurting I just didn't feel
good yeah and I'm like Oh my age is
catching up to me so I was like okay now
it's time for me to like you know really
focus and start you know having
healthier habits so having a six-pack or
getting like buff and physically looking
better was never a goal of mine it was
just like I get rid of this heartburn my
[ __ ] knees hurt my back hurts like
I'm getting [ __ ] up here's some real
[ __ ] yeah it's a real [ __ ] as you get
older like you don't think about these
things and so
um I remember I met this kid and he's uh
I train with him now he's an amazing
Muay Thai Fighter right fire and he fan
two and he's like dude I got fat because
you were fat because I wanted to be fat
like you I was like no I was like what
the [ __ ] are you talking about he goes
dude I've got some [ __ ] influence he
was like you're you're in Muay Thai
since you were a kid you saw me or like
David so fat I'm gonna be fat and I'm
like what the [ __ ] is going on here you
know so I just didn't have the money I
was trying though I was like I wanted to
be fat I just was so poor
so oh my God you know I started posting
these videos and this guy you know
clearly he's just like oh the way you
put your Technique I'm like I don't
really care about this stuff but he was
like I can't wait till I smash her
[ __ ] face it and I'm like oh where
does this guy live and
I was like okay cool so you know hit up
my coach or whatever I'm like let's get
this guy in no way I'm not scared like
if and he was like I'm a pro boxer I did
all this other [ __ ] I'm like
I'm pretty sure you're not because a pro
boxer would never comment on my random
[ __ ] training video yeah you know
what I mean so I'm like oh I was like
this might be a great video so I was
like Hey I want you to come into my gym
shut up come [ __ ] me up whenever you
want come on I was like I was like come
on in and teach me [ __ ] me up do it and
then he just like you're just lucky I
had this [ __ ] disease now oh
oh no oh now you got a doctor's note
like what the [ __ ] are you talking about
so he wanted to smash your face in like
five minutes ago and if he can I would
love for him to do it that'll just
motivate me to get better so I was like
come on in and he was like no it's like
you don't even know how to [ __ ] I was
like here's the address here's the spot
here's my coach you're gonna have to
sign this affidavit right you'll sign
this waiver and then we could just spar
right and if you want to do it without
Spar we'll keep it just in the comments
in the comments I totally dm'd you yeah
exactly I was like were we pulling up
yeah
well the guy was like saying uh now he's
now he's saying he's a gang member I'm
like you're not a gang member bro like
you don't beg at all I know for a fact
you don't bang because I'm not even in
like the the radar of somebody who does
[ __ ] like this so I asked a couple of
friends it was out in Long Beach I'm
like who's this guy he's like he's Long
Beach he's like I don't know who the
[ __ ] said no Hill
hit this guy up kept on tell him come on
in like the Cambodian friends up yeah I
was like come on in because like he's a
nobody right but if he's a real fighter
I would like to test myself let's see it
happening yeah it would be a great video
in this video if I get beat up I'll
still post it up yeah I don't give a
[ __ ] it's content let's go do it this
guy's [ __ ] dodging this [ __ ] like a
politician and I'm like all right man
you're not a fighter and it made me a
little sad because I wanted a dope video
I was like I would be adult video see if
I get beat up or to see if he'll beat me
up because usually when I train I train
with friends and we don't ever get angry
and I don't like being mad so like when
I would go to like some of these other
gyms some people like when they see a
new person come in they want to test
their skills out and it just gets into a
brawl and I hated it every that's why I
stopped training at random gyms because
when you're also somebody with a name to
you they want that video clip of you
beating up this quote-unquote YouTuber
yeah and so
I've had like um instances where I went
to a gym and I've talked about this
years ago but it was when I first
started it was like this guy just
started swinging at me lo and behold I
[ __ ] knocked this dude out at a gym
and I was like hey this shouldn't they
should have never gotten to this point
yeah right entirely and of course he was
recording it I don't see the [ __ ]
footage how come you didn't post it
because he wanted to record this I
didn't even know that they were
recording and so he wanted that clip of
oh I beat up this YouTube but then this
fool just [ __ ] cracked he gets like
TKO like in a sparring session and he's
just like wobble nothing yeah but he
didn't post the video yeah let's get
that clip yeah let me get the clip let
me post that [ __ ] clip and that
wasn't very good either but he wasn't
good either at all right it was but
that's like the delusion that happens
and you know typically I don't really
put a lot of um time and effort into
those comments but I wanted a video out
of it oh yeah and I tried it two or
three times but once again people who
are good Fighters will never do that to
me because they know I'm not on their
level so why the [ __ ] would they waste
their time on me yeah they wouldn't do
that so just so you never got to do the
video no he just I I hit him up multiple
times he just didn't want to come in so
I just blocked him at that point because
I want the smoke yeah the smoke yeah and
I was like it would have been a light
Spar session unless he swung at me yeah
that's that's the thing at the end of
the day people
I don't know what it is it's it's the
energy thing it's like you had the
energy it's like what you said it's like
some people just get up and
crave that [ __ ] yeah like there's
violence they choose violence like the
minute they wake up this is violence
they're like David So posted a fitness
Muay Thai video
yeah and I'm always just like that's
what I'm saying like take that effort
and then focus on yourself man yes yeah
you would like the amount of energy you
put into this dude you could have no
idea how successful you would be yeah
you would probably kill it if you're
waking up every day devising this
probably has like a task list you know
yeah you're pretty focused just focus on
whatever your own craft is like
eventually you'll get somewhere with it
and I always want people to be
successful because successful people are
happy and they stop [ __ ] with people
because they're just doing their own
thing like I I dealt with this one
person recently like a few years ago and
she just went off the rails and this
person is just like consistently just
hating on me all the time because I had
to cut her out and all of our friends
had to cut her out and you know I had a
friend too
who was a friend with this person and
they just don't talk to them anymore
because they all they do is talk [ __ ]
about me and horrible friends and then
the only thing I say is like listen
don't wish bad on pondering because when
she's successful and she's happy she's
gonna stop being so angry yeah if I wish
bad things upon her she's just gonna
keep going through this cycle of death
all the time and she has absolutely no
[ __ ] friends so I want her to have
friends I want her to be successful I
want her to be happy because she'll stop
[ __ ] with people yeah yeah that's
right it's yeah it's entirely true
because
um
yeah that's actually a really good
takeaway like happy like when you're
happy and when you feel like you're
you're in your purpose you kind of
forget about the negativity and you're
just all of a sudden you're just you're
like I'm doing my thing and that's kind
of why we've been able to because you
know [ __ ] happens you know there there's
been many times where people try to
cross me or try to cross her and it
comes down to like
is my energy worth this right now yeah
yeah and because it's like because mind
you like you know if we wake up and we
go to sleep and we're dead tired at
night
we need that energy to do the things
that we got to do that make us happy
that pay the bills that like you know
keep our success story going whereas if
we spent an ounce of that energy on
something else we might not be able to
perform something else because we you
know our energy is like a daily thing
yeah energy is everything yeah
everything so we hold we hold energy
dear so
yeah that's that's a really good
takeaway though yeah I mean like I said
when I when I watch your guys's content
is interesting like you know from Fran
from fan and now we're slowly becoming
friends and then now you guys are people
who I look like like when you started
making videos it made me happy so like
oh maybe I want to start creating videos
again because you know I'm busy like
Billy like I want to do it there's a lot
of stuff that next year you know after
I'm done building the store like I do
want to get back into creating content
and we could create content together too
like I would love to like
I just shot myself
like there's there's stuff that you
could probably delve into that you've
never done like
um
[ __ ] you might even I might even give
you a chance to like direct something
with dialogue in it it'd be something
different it'd be fun it'd be fun you
know what I mean and like I always like
working with people that I like like
there's definitely people who have done
a lot of great things like but I don't
really know you don't want to work with
you right because everything I do is for
fun yeah uh everything I do is for my
purpose of like growth and fun if it
doesn't have that I don't really care
it's it's hard for people in like
traditional Hollywood to understand that
right they go well why don't you
audition for this TV show it's like I
don't like the TV show yep and they go
well it'll be a great I don't care like
I just I just don't care you know yeah
so it's it's hard right because some
people look at this as an opportunity as
a job which is great if that's your
passion it's not mine and you can't put
your goals onto me so period yeah that's
just what it is like you're you're
basing my happiness on your happiness so
if they go oh well here's this great
movie deal you know why don't you
audition for it or try it out it's like
I read the script I hate it and they go
well Bakers can't be choosers who says
I'm a beggar
why am I why am I a beggar like I'm not
a beggar like I've built my own path
we've all everybody in this room has
done things that they want to do in the
way that they wanted it and then we
become successful doing it yeah so why
are we Beggars now because I'm not I
don't want to do the traditional route
that you're going through
yeah it's the it's that
the the old way of like
you have to do it in this way
it's an old concept that's why gold
concept one of the things that blew my
mind was during the time like you know I
did the film I was like doing the
Netflix shows or whatever but then I saw
somebody who I really look up to and
I've never met is actually Casey neistat
and Casey neistat has done everything
but he says the the most fulfillment
that he gets is his YouTube he's done
everything and he keeps going back to
YouTube and because I came from like
this sense of wanting to be the biggest
stand-up in doing all this traditional
stuff
I didn't realize that what I was doing
that was negatively affecting me was
like chasing after this thing that I
never wanted it's because I wanted the
notoriety of like oh this guy is like
the best actor it's like wait hold on a
second look at Casey neistat he has it
all yeah but he loves his YouTube the
most because there's no red tape we
don't have to ask permission to do [ __ ]
we're not signing affidavits or whatever
we're just creating and we're enjoying
what we're doing and so when I see what
you guys create and which is very hard
to do by the way to have a like a social
media couple that [ __ ] kills it thank
you it's actually very hard having that
right because I think creatively you
guys work well together and like hearing
both of your guys's stories you guys
actually have a very similar mind state
which is like number one first and
foremost is doing things that make you
happy and also working hard at it too at
the same time because a lot of people
chase happiness but they forget about
the hard work yeah and we'll deal with
the hard work they're not happy they
don't know what's going on but hearing
your story about you just [ __ ] like
listen
no school I'm gonna come to LA and I'm
gonna work my ass off because a lot of
people do that but they don't work their
ass off and they wonder why they didn't
make it 100 yeah and so I love what you
did like it's it's pretty [ __ ]
amazing so when I hear these stories on
this podcast I always like hearing this
this is like the important part nobody
would have guessed like oh you know
[ __ ] this will live in the car eating
[ __ ] peanut butter and Top Ramen all
day you know not at the same time at the
same time he took his feet up later
you know going to [ __ ] did you like
shower at 24 hours and [ __ ]
um
if it was if I was lucky I would however
I went so
they know this by now Millennium dance
complex period I would go in the morning
before anyone got there and Jin Lee
she's one of the you know she's like one
of the higher-ups there
and this is the old location she at the
end there was a long hallway and I would
go in through the back door like you
know like because the door was open like
you know for anyone to hang out in there
but it would be like 9 A.M it'd be like
or even earlier than that sometimes and
it's like oh and she would look down at
the hallway see me with like my little
my little gym bag and she'd be like
and I would just I would go in the
bathroom and just you know wipe myself
down making myself clean you know if I
take a little ghetto bath you know the
whole showers yeah
I got good at that that ended up being
part of the routine so it was just like
you know and they you know because they
saw that they they uh
actually scholarshiped me
um yeah they they look they're like hey
we you know General's like hey I I see
that you know I'm not gonna ask about
your situation but um would you like to
you know like would you like to take
classes here for free and like you know
do all you know and uh sub sometimes you
know help us out and stuff and I was
like yes [ __ ] yeah please let's just
please so they you know I'm someone that
I struggled but I recognize all of the
help I got along the way yeah and I owe
my success to those people and those
people were people that were at the
wedding and people that I talked to now
and we all have great connections and we
keep those connections we don't believe
in Burning Bridges unless they have to
be burned yeah yeah yeah yeah so isn't
that trippy it might be trippy for
people who have seen both you guys like
just start off and be like look at what
the [ __ ] like this is crazy because I
think about that too when I see some of
my friends who who I was acting with in
sketches and I've thought that they were
the best actors now they're on TV shows
they're doing all the stuff that's
[ __ ] amazing crazy like it's crazy
like even what even watching from
growing up I've seen some of the people
that you've worked with like you know
like including yourself
growing in the ways that you are like
now with everything you got with the
podcast from your stores that you got
opening up your multiple businesses like
know that
myself as a viewer and as you know
someone's been watching you for 10 years
plus
I see your journey too and like I'm
proud that I've been watching you for so
long and that I'm at this point now
where I'm like
holy [ __ ] we're here this is crazy but
isn't that trippy though like life life
is so [ __ ] fascinating how it works
out that way right and like I all these
curveballs is what makes life really
exciting yeah and so entirely you know
sometimes when people think that you
know I'm pretty sure when people who
look up to you guys now they think that
you have everything figured out it's
like we have nothing figured out
no [ __ ] nope I'm still figuring it out
social media
be on our social medias because we
understand how it can be a blessing and
a curse like you get to share what you
love on there but then the curse can be
you know you have a bad day you go on
social media and then you compare
yourself like naturally like that
happens like that even happens to me as
well and it's like a highlight reel on
social media when you can be having the
worst day ever and then you can go
online and then see all the amazing
things that your friends and all your
peers are doing and then you're like
what the [ __ ] am I doing like in
comparison is the thief of Joy so like
it's it's important to keep that
authenticity on social media and
yeah I it's definitely I don't even know
why I brought that up my brain just went
but like where did that come from what
were we just talking about before this
my brain farts sometimes no it was great
I mean that's what I'm saying like yeah
you I get caught up in that sometimes
too right like I think like I'll be
sitting around and because I'm working
on the store I haven't been able to be
creative and sometimes I'm thinking like
oh [ __ ] like they're doing these new
projects or whatever well I want to do
that too but then I have to stay focused
on my path right it's like yes and I'm
one of those people that I have to see
things through completion like this door
has taken up two years of my life and
you know I think for a lot of people
it's like oh are you auditioning I'm
like no I'm not doing any of that [ __ ] I
need to get this done right like I'm I'm
wanting to do this right now but because
I've dedicated this and a lot of time
and a lot of [ __ ] money I have to get
this done so
um I try not to live in like five nights
like that it's like I'll get there we'll
we'll do that [ __ ] and I've seen other
people who are active friends of mine
who are just popping off and they're six
years it older than me so what the [ __ ]
am I complaining about you know oh yeah
like we'll we'll all get there and then
you know time like goals will constantly
change the goal post constantly moves I
wanted to be the biggest stand-up and
then I was like wait no I like YouTube
I wanted to be a dancer and here I am
I'm doing content Direction now yeah
which is [ __ ] amazing and it's just a
different chapter in your life and it
feels great to who knows what you'll be
in the next you know five ten years from
now you might do the answer you might be
you're going back to being a dancer
we're going all the way back
she would yeah we're constantly growing
and evolving I love it every day I want
to get into acting you could do it you
[ __ ] do it I want to do that you know
there's just [ __ ] do it
well this is the thing too
um when people ask like how do I get in
the stand up I was like yeah go to Open
Mic you grab a mic make some jokes and
guess what you're a stand-up now doesn't
mean you're good or whatever but that's
all that it takes it takes so yeah it's
action that's all that it takes you go
because I mean think about it like this
when people oh are you an actor what
makes an actor an actor there's no
credentials like you go audition you
audition and now guess what you're a
[ __ ] actor do it you know that's
really what it is yeah I don't believe
in like the hoity-toityness of you know
having to always like prove your Worth
to everybody yeah like you just got to
do it to yourself so if you want to be
an actor just go [ __ ] out there and
just do it and if it doesn't work out it
doesn't [ __ ] work out oh well back to
the drawings true yeah do it again who
the [ __ ] cares like at the end of the
day
who the [ __ ] cares exactly we're all
gonna die you know that's all that's all
I know is that we all gonna die so I
just want to do things that I want to do
and try it out that's why I've done so
many random [ __ ] because and I failed so
much like a lot but it's just kind of
like helps me check that that little
list off it's like oh I tried it didn't
like it cool move on yeah it makes me
feel like I can Live Without Regrets
right so I don't ever want to do
something or not do something because
I'm scared right because at the end of
the day we're all gonna die what's going
to happen if I if I fail nothing
it's not a waste of time I learned
something I'm like oh this is not for me
right because I for a second that I was
like maybe I want to try a you know
eventually go into amateur boxing and
pro boxing I got punched in the face I'm
like not for me I was like I think I
like hitting the pads and I don't like
it when they hit me yeah I have a
question for you yeah if you could go
back in time and relive One Moment in
your life what would you choose to
relive man that's a good question
um
I don't know if I
want to relive moments and I've
literally maybe like before I go to
sleep I've thought about this multiple
times it's like what are these points in
my life that were so centrifugal to who
I am now that I would either change or
do something different and how would it
have changed the trajectory of my life
right what if I never dated that first
girl that I that I ever dated would I be
the person that I am now
um what if I went back in time and then
I all the knowledge that I have now
um would change the trajectory of my
life for something better but when I
think about that stuff I also think
about because of all the [ __ ] that I
had to go through it's why I'm here now
because if let's say let's say for
example like this let's say
I can record all my content go back in
time right and then upload and reshoot
everything but make these small little
tweaks right okay it would definitely
change the directly because I because
the knowledge I gained and how to film
how to light all this stuff my videos
would look so different yeah right and
it would be a lot more concise and
better I would make better moves but
then at the same time if I reach this
level of success would I have met this
person would I have met that person it
changes everything yeah everything
[ __ ] changes so it's hard to say I I
don't think I want to relive or redo
anything because I am who I am now
because of those things that have
happened and
um it's just I just don't want to change
that [ __ ] right because imagine if I
could I have appreciated the
relationship I had with my mother if I
didn't fight with her so much um
don't think I could have right
um would I have
had all these stupid funny stories if I
didn't go through all the [ __ ]
because of all these trials and
tribulations I'm allowed to be a comic
because I can I've coped with it by
flipping it and turning into comedy
exactly if everything was perfect I
wouldn't have any of this [ __ ] if I
didn't [ __ ] up and have that guy pull
that gun on me I wouldn't have that
story to tell here exactly right so no I
wouldn't change [ __ ] because it's all
important it's everything it changed my
my perspective of how I think about
things how I develop friendships
relationships I probably would have
never met you guys wow you know it's
what makes you David so exactly so like
for all like imagine if you didn't go to
the struggles of living through your
living with your car and making that
move here you probably would have never
met JoJo no so would you want to take
these this struggle story out because
look at what happened at the end you met
this woman yeah and now you guys are
married so that you would have to take
that away
you know because imagine if you weren't
that guy that was like starving and
pretending like you're a super super
maybe she would have found you sexy
foreign
that guy's chipper he's not mysterious
enough exactly he doesn't look starving
enough and then you're sitting here like
well how come she doesn't find me
attractive I'm not hungry because I had
lunch
I love this [ __ ] well guys that wraps up
this episode of The Genius brain podcast
I hope you are inspired by this
um hope you enjoyed their stories you
could check out both of them on their
social media shout out your guys
yourselves out I'm JoJo Gomez EXO and at
rude Koji on Instagram so amazing take
JoJo's dance classes if you if you out
there and you really about that [ __ ] all
right you gotta come through are you
about that [ __ ] I would explode my hips
and knees I literally watch your [ __ ]
and I get anxiety but it would be good
content if I'm in the hospital after it
was great content
make sure you like And subscribe so I'm
just being [ __ ] wheeled out
twerking class with Jojo and David So
coming soon now let's get it oh yeah and
then of course Donovan amazing amazing
videographer does just about everything
photos are [ __ ] amazing he's a dancer
multi-hyphen a talented guy check him
out
um you can catch genius brain every
Sunday at 12pm see you all next time
peace
[Music]